[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
learning X
I am no stranger to sharing with you the
process behind my Unreal Engine
Creations however today we're doing
things a little differently I'm going to
take you behind the scenes to follow me
on a journey to create my next music
video in I'm your engine five a gaping
mouth Falls below your head
somewhere deep inside
[Music]
[Laughter]
so the song itself was actually based on
a poem that I wrote quite a while ago
based around mental health and how it
can manifest itself into a monstrous
form sometimes
I have almost finished the song working
with my producer Jamie at Horizon
Productions we finished recording all
the vocals and the guitar pieces and he
has done some Stella monster voice
performances if you want to check out
Jamie at Horizon Productions there will
be a link in the description down below
we've also messed around with changing
audio from everyday sounds such as a
bobble head into something very uncanny
which fits with the otherworldly
Ambience of the narrative that I was
going for and when the song is almost
done that's when I know it's time to
think about what I'm gonna do for the
music video itself
whenever I create anything in Unreal
Engine I always start with the
constraints so the constraints that we
have here are time which is until
October the 31st so around about three
months however that's a free time so
it's probably more like a week a few
weeks something like that uh I also
don't have an animator I don't have an
environment artist I don't have people
like this to work with however I do have
Braden who is more than happy to do
simple uh models for me as well as some
art so thank you Braden I did actually
do a whole mood board on Twitch and a
lot of you join me there so thank you
for watching and that was a try and get
a feel for what kind of vibe we wanted
for the music video
we ended up going for a kind of PS1
retro kind of vibe think siren or the
old Silent Hill or Resident Evil games
this is because not only are they creepy
but also it's a little bit more
attainable as it's only low poly models
and also it's just something that both
myself and Braden are interested in as I
really feel it's important when you have
a team or you're working with other
people to make sure that they also feel
invested and are excited about the
project that you're making once I'd
figured out all of this I started to put
together a Google Document of everything
from the song The Narrative of the song
the mood board that was created in
twitch and what we both wanted to get
out of this music video
so first of all I needed to find out a
way that I could not only have low poly
models and textures but also how to have
graphical errors as that really is what
makes the old PS1 games look quite
uncanny and surreal but lucky for me I
stumbled upon retrographics by Marcis
and this had everything I needed to
create an authentic old-school Retro
Game look it has everything from
dithering to depth errors and even
allowing you options for fog and lens
flares I'll put a link in the
description below for it if you would
like to check it out yourself I also
knew that I wanted to insert myself into
the music video because that's just
something that I always do and when we
were doing our mood board we looked at
siren and it really inspired me how they
had created their character models faces
because they used images of real people
as textures for the face and this
created a really super creepy effect
that still holds up today the character
model for the siren characters are low
poly and for the faces they have just
noses eight different camera angles will
be used to take pictures of the actors
doing different facial expressions and
then these will be used for textures to
use on the model's faces they would
blend over one another to create this
really awesome effect I figured I might
be able to do this in Unreal Engine
using a flip book material which is
something that I've done in the past
when I just did like 2D Sprite
animations so that's the way that I'm
gonna try what I've done so far is
basically prototypes are very crude
character that uses a stink machine to
drive its different animations through
an animation blueprint these different
animation States transition based on an
enumerator which which can be controlled
through a level sequence by making sure
that the enumerator variable is exposed
to cinematics upon a state change the
animation blueprint sends off a delegate
which the character blueprint itself
binds to this then updates a material on
the face itself depending on what the
enumerator is
or in my case I've literally just used a
sphere for now that is attached to the
Head bone it doesn't look very good but
um I'm getting somewhere so my thoughts
are that this is how I can easily change
which flip book material I'm using for
the facial expressions along with what
animation I'm using for the character
itself through the level sequencer so
I'll have full control and that's enough
technical jargon
so the next steps are for Brayden to
create a low poly character model for me
to then practice out giving it
animations through using probably miximo
and we'll also have to take some images
of my facial expressions so I can try
out turning them into textures and using
them in the flipbook materials I have
set up to see if this technique is
actually going to work or not and once I
have a good idea of what I can do within
Unreal Engine and what systems I have to
be creative with that's when I'll feel
able and ready to do a storyboard for
the music video I'm from the storyboard
I can then let my artist know what low
poly environment assets I'll need to
create the music video we still have a
lot more work to do but I'm pretty happy
with the direction that we're going in
do I think we'll get it done in time I
have not a clue but I will try my best
and that's all we can really do so
thanks for watching this update video
maybe it was inspiring or interesting I
don't know I just thought I would share
with you the journey as I take it
because there are many changes that get
made along the way when you create
something like this thanks a lot to my
patreons who helped make this all a
reality honestly all of your support
means so so very much to me and I will
be sending you the demo of the song that
we are working on so you can see the
crappy demo version that I created in my
bedroom enjoy that and if you want to
support in any other way there is a
little thank you button down there so uh
if you want though you can hit that but
it's completely up to you and I don't
like asking
have a lovely day evening I will see you
in the next update video bye
[Music]
thank you
sorry pardon me
okay it's getting it all out I can feel
it in there it's really annoying
I don't know